hey everyone this is International
master David Bruce for chest comm and
today I'm going to teach you the most
popular defense for black to 1.e4 and
that is the Sicilian after this video
you will be ready to play it so on the
Sicilian defense goes c5 like this and
that's it you're ready go play the
Sicilian just kidding okay what's the
point of this move here which doesn't
really develop black pieces that much
although it lets the Queen move the main
point of this opening is simply to
control d4 so that white can't put two
pawns next to each other in the center
so that's basically white strategic
threat in this position is to play d4
and establish a duo of pawns controlling
four squares in the center if I can get
that duo so black is going to prevent
that with c5 now the main way white
usually responds to the Sicilian is to
play Knight f3 and then on the next move
d4 now it's called the open Sicilian and
after black takes white puts the knight
in the center so white trades off his
central pawn for blacks not as central
pawn but what White's trying to do is
develop quickly and post their pieces
aggressively in the center taking
advantage of the fact that c5 didn't
really develop black as quickly as it
developed white now if you want to learn
more about the open Sicilian we have
separate videos for each of these
different variations that black can play
in the open Sicilian like how to play
the night or if how to play the
Scheveningen how to play this fashion
ACOG etc so you can look those up but
what I'm going to talk about right now
are the other things that white can do
other than the open Sicilian and sort of
the point of the Sicilian so there are
two principle other things that white
can do one is to play some kind of a
system with c3 trying to play d4 and be
able to put two pawns in the center
anyway right by recapturing with a pawn
now in general if white plays c3
planning to play d4 there's no reason
you should allow white to get that
perfect center so in chess to play well
you want to get used to seeing what the
upsides and downsides of different moves
are the upside of c3 is to be able to
play
or the downside is taking away the best
development square from this night so
what black should do is they should
fight white for these two squares while
white is busy taking over this square
here okay you're not going to be able to
stop d4 powered by the white queen so go
after these two squares and there are
two variations black and play here that
give black and acceptable game one is
Knight f6 attacking this pawn after it
advances you come here and white plays
d4 but his central pawns are already
they're not standing next to each other
so they're not as flexible and black you
know can trade this pawn easily with d6
if he wants to the second thing that
black can do about c3 is he can play d5
and whites just going to have to trade
pawns right away black will play Queen
takes d5 which often you won't want your
Queen here but the main reason you won't
want your Queen there is because of
Knight c3 which is now impossible so
white will play d4 and black will just
developing the game will continue with
this pawn tension here for a little
while and you may eventually get upon
trade on one square the other you'll
almost certainly get a pawn trade on one
of those two squares but black should be
able to develop successfully so the
second thing that white can do in
general is to basically play with a pawn
on d3 and keep the position closed and
they're not usually going to start with
d3 but they're going to play you know
something like Knight c3 and then
depending on how black develops White's
usually going to put their Bishop on g2
and upon on d3
and these variations here are called the
closed variation of the Sicilian or the
Kings Indian attack sometimes and
they're generally going to be
characterized by white having space over
here on the Kings side and black having
space over here on the Queen side okay
it's also possible if you want as black
that you can try to respond by setting
up pawn tension in the center with d5
and then you can get positions that look
like this where the two sides have pawn
tension like this but each side is sort
of supporting their own
so that's another big thing you can get
out of the Sicilian into clothes
variations is you can get this kind of
tension between these two ponds and I'll
just mention one other thing that white
can do in the Sicilian which is they can
start with Knight f3 and now black plays
Knight c6 or d6 white can play Bishop to
b5 check and I've tonight 1 c6 it won't
be checked but it would still be this
should be 5 and you can often trade this
bishop and get Spanish or Rui Lopez type
games where White's castling and then
they might play d3 and keep it close or
they might play c3 d4 they've got a lot
of options the one thing to note is that
white cannot really play a good Bishop
b5 against ecigs because there's no
piece to trade on and black just gains
time for their natural Queen side
expansion against White's Bishop all
right so that's the Sicilian defense I
hope you enjoyed this video and I'll see
you around on chess calm